but cole irvin one start against the
angels
that was on may the 30th he gave up six
hits total
five unfortunately in one inning four
runs in the one inning
upton goes to third one away and that'll
bring up max stassi
and max dassey has a base hit to make it
one-nothing angels
talk about jumping the count first pitch
double
first pitch rbi singles now taylor ward
and ward has a base hit stasi coming
around
throw from canna will be offline in late
two-nothing halos
taylor ward lines that one another wells
place baseball but kana gets to that
baseball right as staff he's on the bag
but it did not stop
here's the 01 pitch and cole deals and
that swung on that's hit to left field
hit well canada going back
at the track right to the wall reaching
up he makes a phenomenal catch
crashes up against the wall gets up
fires the ball back to the infield
and the runners get back well what a
play
save two runs and mark canna catches it
bangs against the wall and immediately
you watch the base runners
iglesias had gone almost to third ward
had actually rounded second but smart
enough to retrace his steps touched the
back going back boy that saves one
possibly
two runs from scoring now phil goslin
who bounces the first pitch up the
middle another base hit
boy swing it early iglesias scores
easily
it's griffin canning making his 11th
start of the year here this afternoon
coming off a win wednesday against
kansas city
in which he went into the seventh inning
allowing only one earned run
and matt olson has a base hit into right
field
maybe more he's on his way in a second
the throw there is not in time
that will likely be scored as a single
in an error for olson
really really close i don't know hey i
don't mind that now
take a look it might be worth a
challenge and he's out
yeah calls over turn so now shohei otani
banning with two out and the bases empty
well and that one he did it again
got him number 19 for shohei ohtani
he is the good hands people will not
swing
shohei otaki breaking ball
wow how strong he is i just love that
that facial expression as he crushes
that baseball
mitch moreland veteran left-handed d-h
got the night off yesterday
you know here's another positive number
for griffin
as moreland sends a high-fly ball out to
left oh
man how did iglesias catch that
what do we call that gooby the magician
havana
magic wow again
this is pretty close there's no way
i'm not looking i'm just catching he has
got nothing but the sun in his eyes
he peels out looks to the ground and
flags it down
tony kemp will be the next spatter
another fly ball into the sunfield
no we did not come on havana magic
unreal that is incredible he's done this
twice today
i have no idea gossip is looking like i
don't know and look at that play
oh the raiders are coming back hopefully
they wanted to come back and say why did
you work russell in special teams on
punts
so two away here in the fourth inning
and now to the top deodorant update here
comes the
one basketball high fly ball to center
loriano
going back toward the track near the
wall jumps at the wall
and ramon loriano is back in the house
a great catch by ramon like he never
left
and it's a one two three inning for
urban and the athletics
so here is ramon well it's standard
practice now that
the laser gets himself a knock right
it's this one the left it's hit well
and that baby's gone
deep up the stairway now they got him
twice
in uh 19 and make it one and 21.
and no doubt top pan with the axe handle
he makes a home run he saves the run and
drives it around with one swing in the
back
it is gone and now they have a pair of
runners on
and seth brown will be the next batter
the next one
too and he gets him on a much better
breaking ball that time
we get ready to move to the bottom of
the fifth inning griffin canning will be
facing elvis andrews to start things off
next delivery swings at that one lifts
it in the air into right center and
there is taylor ward
boy the angels outfielders have been
very busy in this spa game and again
there has not been a single ground out
recorded behind canning so far these are
in business here now with the top of the
order coming up
and comes to the plate and it's a swing
and a ground ball to short iglesias as
it goes to second
relay by fletcher the first and not
quite in time
as the run scores it's now a four to two
ball game
so bert smith comes in to face upton
gosselin at third fletcher at first
swing and a miss he stayed with a fast
ball and he threw it by update
there's chapman right-handed hitter two
on nobody out
he's down two we're in the sixth and
that swung on a ground ball into left
center for a base hit
olson around third coming to the plate
there'll be no throw
and the answer down by one right through
the shift
here's pinder pinder hitting for brown
and that's a line drive base in left
field
lowry's being waved home lowry's gonna
score
going to third as chapman going the
second is pinder and this game is tied
at four
they're gonna walk elvis anders so the
bases will be loaded with nobody out
shallow center a thing of beauty chapman
comes in to score pinder stops there
kemp comes through again and the a's
lead 5-4
it's 5-4 base is still loaded sea check
comes in to face
hermes garcia he's all over the place
again
right to the backstop and hustling in
the score is pinder
6-4 he's looking for some contact here
which would likely
give the is their seventh run fletcher's
coming home the throw is high
everybody's safe anders scores and it's
7-4
drive to right and that's a base hit
kemp will trot home
he'll score kenneth digging around
second goes to third
and the beginning continues it's now
eight to four olsen has three hits
lou trevino for the final three out
here's the 3-2 again
swung on a foul tip held by garcia and
trevino wins the battle on a fast ball
in 98.
up the middle indus near the bag at
second throws and that's the second out
trevino grabs it he throws and olson
grabs it and that's the ball game
so the a's finish off the three-game
sweep of
the los angeles angels of anaheim